Hello Ornella.
Thank you very much
for being part
of this workshop
organized by
African Futures Action Lab
in collaboration with
the members of CaCoBuRwa,
the collective of Congolese, Burundian
and Rwandan associations.
We asked you because we would like to...
we saw in the whole debate
on the question of colonial memories,
of the way in which we can tackle the injustices
of colonization,
the colonial crimes,
we constantly need to
refer to the archives,
we need to... it is an element...
The archival component is a central element.
Hence, when you are not a historian,
you are not familiar with the archives.
There are a lot of questions
that we ask ourselves
and therefore we asked you,
as a historian who has worked
and still works
on the colonial archives of Belgium,
to enlighten us regarding
the complexity of the archives.
Perhaps before we start
with a series of questions,
can you tell us
a little bit
about your background?
Hello and thank you
very much for this invitation.
I am a historian,
trained in contemporary history.
In fact, my research is focused on the history
of justice and on the history of Rwanda,
but also, more recently,
of Burundi and of Congo.
My specialty
is judicial archives,
which are in fact documents that historians -
as we were just talking about - are extremely enthusiastic about
because these archives
offer a whole series of perspectives.
One of the questions
that motivated my research
is also to try to see what we can do
with these archives.
I hope that there are points of association
with the debates that concern
your seminar and your projects.
Yes, great.
In any case, we are delighted
to have you here.
One of the questions that is
currently preoccupying us is to know,
if we want to understand the crimes
committed during colonization,
to what extent the path of the archives
is an appropriate way?
To what extent
is it possible to go that way?
What do we...
So the measures are costly.
What does that entail
in terms of the narratives
that we have access to?
To what extent is it limited?
Can you start
with this first big question?
Is this a way to understand
the injustices of colonization?
The first element is to recall that the archives,
which are documents that were produced
by public or private institutions,
or even individuals,
companies,
religious congregations,
these archives, which will be
found on several media,
can be written archives,
or iconographic documents.
A whole series
of documents, maps...
These archives
are the raw material of historians.
It can also be oral archives.
Thus, I do not exclude the oral history from that, of course.
What does this raw material
allow us to do?
Well, it allows us
to observe the past.
This observation of the past
involves a whole series of questions.
When we are faced with a document
that has been produced and preserved,
it is perhaps a question to which
we will be able to come back;
obviously, it is which documents are finally reaching us
today from this period of colonization?
Well, when we are faced with this archive, we ask
a series of questions, we come up with a number of questions.
The objective of this archive and its use
will be to contribute to answering them
from a certain point of view.
There were several questions
within this first question.
That is to say that the archive is produced
by an archive producer who describes in a certain way
the reality of that time,
but of course, it is a point of view.
So the whole point of using archives
is to be aware of this standpoint, to deconstruct it,
to question it and to confront it
with other points of view.
This is what we call the crossing of sources.
A single archive will not give us
direct access to the past
as it was at that time.
It will give us access to a vision of this past,
which was the actual present at the time.
Thus, to approach these questions,
we must not exclude
all the other social and human sciences,
political sciences, jurists,
anthropologists
who also use archives.
Historians do
what is called historical criticism
and it is a whole series of methods, tools,
and questioning that allow us
to put this archive in context and try
to question it to the best of our ability.
To answer the question: do archives
allow you to document or understand,
to question the injustices
of the colonial past?
It is certainly an essential element
in which we can find a certain number of answers
because it is this raw material
that gives us access to this past.
Now, as I was saying, everything also
depends on what we obtain.
The archive is produced at a certain moment
and then it will be preserved or not.
This conservation will depend
on intellectual decisions.
Does this archive have sufficient
historical value to allow us to keep it?
It will also depend, of course,
on the preservation and transmission conditions
with the possibility of archives
that can be degraded, lost or destroyed.
We had floods recently, in Belgium,
which had an impact on a certain number of archives
that suffered,
that could have been destroyed.
So there are voluntary and involuntary causes,
of course, of the destruction of these archives.
So, public archives and private archives
reach us in a way
that I would say
is sometimes not complete.
If we now return to the specific
question of colonial archives,
we are faced with another question:
these are archives that were produced
in multiple places.
We were talking about Congo, Burundi and Rwanda,
three geographical areas that have their own history,
which therefore produced their own archives;
these archives were produced
in Africa, but also in Belgium.
Thus, we have collections that are split between the two.
At the end of the 1950s, in fact, in 1960,
these archives were partially repatriated
to Belgium. This means that we have documents
that have remained on site
and we have documents that have been repatriated.
I think that we estimate that today, more or less,
there are ten kilometers of so-called African archives,
colonial archives, they go by several names,
that are kept in Belgium.
Some documents were left behind,
some are still preserved today.
Others have unfortunately disappeared
or have been destroyed over time.
These colonial or African archives,
well, we'll see what term we use here,
have one particularity, which is
that they are part of a sort of triptych.
Between memory, justice and history.
Clearly, the question that you ask
is the question of the mobilization
of these archives and through justice,
as we saw with the Mestizo trial in Belgium.
Through memory, we see it through collectives,
through what we call civil society.
As well as through history, because historians
have been working on these archives for years.
It is that nowadays, we see that there is
an extremely strong demand for history
and that the discourse on history is carried
by many players, including non-historians.
It is very good that way.
Just to say that yes,
archives are fundamental,
but they are not the only source of information
that allows us to observe this past, to question it,
to understand it.
Great. Perhaps to go
a little further
in the questions,
in the elements that you address.
You're describing
a situation in which
archives are located
in several geographic spaces.
The archives are both...
There has been a whole process
of so-called sorting, between...
the moment when
the document was made
and contains a certain point of view,
the document was archived,
the document, we decide whether to keep it
and all the hazards that can...
that can arise afterwards.
As a result,
I say to myself,
in this whole process
where we have partial
and biased views,
what do we...
what do we have...
what do we learn,
amongst other things, about...
I mean, is there a view that emerges
on how these archives were...
well, on the narratives that emerge,
where it was treated or is it that...
we are still examining them
and therefore,
we can't say...
it's impossible to make an inventory of the injustices
of colonization from what has been treated
until now?
There are several things, I would say.
The first point
is that this question of points of view
and of what can be drawn from an archive
is a fundamental question for historians.
Now, I'm talking about my point of view.
It is the one from which I can speak.
It's true that the first question we ask ourselves,
I'll take an example from the court records,
because they are the ones I know best
and where I can give concrete examples.
When we are faced with a court file,
we say to ourselves: OK,
in what context was this file produced?
What are the elements I need
to understand what is going on?
It's not only the context,
it's also to understand the language
of the person who produced
the file at the time?
Who are the players?
What is the architecture, in this case,
of justice such as it functions?
Once I am in front of my file,
what do I find in it?
The judicial archives are a good example
to ask ourselves this question of injustices
and of the way in which,
in this case, the Congolese,
this is the example I have in mind,
interact with the system of justice
that is actually a colonial justice.
What we find in a judicial file
are typically testimonies,
confrontations of points of view
and the determination of facts.
Therefore, it is obviously a fascinating field
for observing the question of violence,
for observing
the question of interactions
between the colonized
and the colonial authorities,
for understanding the way
in which the law is constructed and hence
a form of violence in the sense that the law,
as we know, does not apply in the same way
to whites as to Congolese
if we take this example in a colonial context.
We have specific offences that are defined
in a specific way with specific penalties.
We really have an asymmetrical system
that is actually reflected in these judicial records.
That's one thing,
this entire legal framework
that allows us to question it.
Then there is the other aspect,
which is transversal to all court records
and that is the question of testimony.
When it comes to the question of testimony,
the historian says to himself : “OK, here I will have access
to the voice of the players.”
The voice of the players is also the voice
of the victims, or the voice of the people
who were convicted or prosecuted,
like the accused.
It's extremely exhilarating because we say to ourselves
that we have this capacity for direct observation
to be able to use the expression
of Mary Bloch, a historian, who speaks
of this historical observation by saying :
“The historian will never be an anthropologist.”
He will not be able to go and do fieldwork.
Obviously, we can temper this
because today,
this is the case
but all he can do is this historical
observation through documents.
We're caught up in it.
We say to ourselves: “Yes, with the testimony,
I have access to the voice of the person.”
Obviously, when we talk about judicial testimony,
even archives produced by other types
of public or state institutions,
this voice is filtered.
It is filtered in different ways.
First, it is transcribed.
In this case, we are talking
about written documents?
Who transcribed?
In what language was this person speaking?
It is unlikely that this person
was speaking in French at the time.
However, today, what we read
is a transcription in French.
How was his statement
summarized, interpreted?
Is it consistent with what was said?
Some of these questions are impossible
to resolve, obviously,
for the historian today,
but taking them into account and trying
to find information from even the smallest details
of these testimonies makes it possible
to overcome all the biases
that any archive contains, and this is not
specific to colonial or African archives.
To be able to try to find
this original voice and to put it in relation
with other types of archives,
we could think of oral history campaigns
for more recent periods
that can put this into perspective.
These are things that are being done,
it's not... well it's to be done, of course,
but it's already being done.
So here we are, a judicial file
or an archive file in general
is a document that was produced at a specific moment,
that has its own history and that, finally,
lives again through our own questioning.
I always come back to this question
because I think it is essential.
Of course, there are things that are given in an archive.
The archive is dated.
It contains names,
it contains a place.
It contains, maybe, a description of the facts,
such and such event took place in the military camp of...
the soldier is interrogated
because he is accused of... etc.
In spite of everything, beyond that,
what the archive will be able to deliver
is obviously the questions that we have.
There, it is not only the historians who come
with questions towards the documents,
but they are also the citizens
because the archive
is part of a democratic, state system.
Therefore, everyone must be able
to have access to it for various reasons.
The research is one of them.
Genealogical questions is another one.
Problems of ownership...
There is a whole series of questions... and reasons,
that can lead a person
to want to consult an archive.
I have two other questions.
I don't know if I separate them or if I...
Maybe I'll start with one question
and come back to the other afterwards.
The first one is :
as an ordinary citizen, if we want
to try to understand a little
or at least to look into what has been done,
in the Belgian archives,
what are we faced with?
To take up what you were saying earlier,
the example given of the trial
of the Mestizo during colonization,
the issue in the trial was, well,
one of the issues at stake was access to the archives
and access
to their administrative documents.
So the difficulty was, at least
for all these children who are now adults,
to have access
and to understand what is in it.
Therefore...
even with a set of,
in their case,
legal experts who were supporting them,
it felt like it was a daunting task.
Now what state are they in?
If an average citizen wants to tackle it,
what are the obstacles?
Well, the obstacles for accessing
the archives can be multiple indeed.
Of course, we can talk about the official position
of the opening of archives, but then there is the...
the reality and the difficulties
to access them.
Just one more remark before answering
this question about access in general.
All archives, whether they are produced
by the State or whether they are private
or by individuals, they always have what is called
a legal time limit of opening.
That is to say, that after a certain number of years,
an archive becomes public.
Often, this period is 30 years
for everything that concerns, for example,
what is produced by the State.
Of course, to this 30-year period apply
as many exceptions related to the question of privacy,
related to the question of the classification of documents.
All this is important
to answer the specific question.
If we take court records,
it is 100 years.
It is said that after 100 years,
a judicial archive is public.
So, do we say to ourselves : “Oh, we don't have access to anything at all.”
Of course we do. There are exceptions in the other direction
like exemptions from law to access.
This is typically what researchers do
to have access to documents.
They have to make a request to obtain authorization.
This request may be addressed
to the Archivist General of the Kingdom,
or it may, in the case of certain court records,
be addressed to the College
of Public Prosecutors.
For example, on a previous project,
to be able to access documents
that were less than 100 years old and that dealt
with war crimes trials in Belgium,
I had to make a request to the College
of Public Prosecutors, saying : “ Here we are,
for research reasons with those objectives,
I would like to access such and such documents. ”
It's a process that takes a certain amount of time
and then they give you access.
Now, the problem,
more specifically with African archives,
is that, as we said, these are archives
that have already travelled,
in some instances.
They were “repatriated” in 1960.
They have had a rather eventful history of conservation,
which has gone hand in hand with a history of,
I would say,
rather marked opacity.
These archives, like the archives
of the Ministry of Foreign Affairs
and the archives of the Ministry of Defense, were in fact
considered to be, so-called sensitive archives
that could possibly present a certain danger
if they were accessed for the sake of order
in society, etc. Well, these are
obviously statements...
Well, I put everything in quotes,
but there it is.
This means that for a very long time,
these archives were quite closed,
including to research, but certainly
to ordinary citizens, as you just said.
One of the obstacles
to the opening of these archives,
even from the researcher's point of view,
without going into the question of mobilization
by civil society or by individuals,
was that we lacked the tools.
We lacked the tools to know what existed,
where it was located, how extensive the documents were,
what they contained.
In short, we lacked an inventory.
An inventory or a database that would
make it possible to locate, target and request access
to such and such documents
to answer certain questions.
Obviously, the problem
is exactly the same
for individuals who would like
to access these documents.
So today, we are in a rather different phase,
and here I refer
to the work of my colleagues on the Mestizo project
and to the general archives of the kingdom,
which have published a guide
on the so-called African and colonial archives
in Belgium, which is a guide that is,
I think, 2,000 pages long
and which is accessible
to the public
on the Internet,
and I can provide you with the link.
It explains all of these steps
and says that now what is happening is that
all of these archives that were kept
at the Ministry of Foreign Affairs, which filtered,
and it is they who use the word, my archival colleagues:
“a little in an arbitrary form”,
the documents to which access
was given, are now being repatriated
to the State archives.
This repatriation to the State archives
clearly marks a break with the past
in the sense that the State,
their mission, their first mission,
is to make documents accessible.
Making documents accessible means putting
archivists and researchers on these collections
to study them, to chart them,
to compile inventories,
and to give the public and researchers access
to these documents transparently, because that is
obviously one of the challenges.
It is, finally, equal access to the archives
in a transparent way.
This does not mean that
when an individual, a citizen, has a question
about his family, for example,
he can go to the archives
and they will pull a file from the shelf
that will give all the answers.
Obviously, when you come
with these questions
about your past, you will be confronted
with a whole series of potential sources
that may provide elements
or even just clues.
That is one of the difficulties, obviously,
and archivists are there to accompany
researchers and citizens
in this quest.
However, it's true that this Mestizo trial,
which stems from the Mestizo Resolution was adopted
by the House of Representatives.
Therefore, it was a political decision
at one point to say: “There is a problem with the opening
of the archives, and it must be resolved.”
These archives
must be made accessible.
This debate on the accessibility
of the archives can be found elsewhere.
I mean, we can look at what is happening
in France in relation to the archives
on the relationship between France and Rwanda.
It's exactly the same issues of transparency
and equal access to these archives,
whereas for the moment, we are still
in a rather obscure situation
on the French side.
Yes, I find it interesting,
what you are saying because in fact, it is...
well, this question of access...
is not only a technical issue,
it is above all a political question.
So to speak of equal access,
I find that this term is quite significant
in the way that it reflects
these obstacles
and the...
and what limitation it can have
to be able to understand what there is in the archives.
I had a little question
actually in relation to that.
I was wondering if the...
Does the fact that these archives
have been kept for a long time...
I don't know if we can use the term “hidden”
but in any case inaccessible,
can explain... In fact, does it have
anything to do with the...
well, it helps to explain part of the way
Belgium has dealt with its colonial past?
By that I mean the fact that there's...
I don't think there's much...
There are not many...
history of colonization
that is taught in schools.
It's really very recent.
So, is there a link
between this inaccessibility and the fact
that it has remained a hidden history for a long time?
Well, at least not...
not really present in society.
Yes, there certainly is. I come back
to this triptych of justice, history and memory,
which in the end reflects the different aspects
that come into play in this question.
That is to say, politics,
society in general, justice in the sense that,
in certain cases, reparations can be demanded,
as is the case in the Mestizo trial.
However, we know
of other debates...
in other formerly colonized spaces
where this question may arise.
We have thought of slavery, etc.
Well, this is it.
So, to speak of absen... sorry.
I'm reiterating my idea,
it's not very clear.
So we have this triptych and in this triptych,
I think that there is also...
not only memory, but there is also
research that already exists.
To say that, since 1960, there has been
no research, obviously, would be...
it would be unfair to all the historians,
anthropologists and political scientists,
who have worked on these questions.
Now the question is, how does
this research find
its way into society?
How are they received, financed, supported?
This is where politics comes in, obviously.
Now, what we often see,
well, what I observe
because it's a question that I find interesting
in all the commission studies on the past...
once again in very diverse contexts, is that
sometimes the politicians come and place
some sort of order to look into questions
that have already been dealt with by the researchers.
However, it is true that these commissions
are important, because they allow to put the spotlight
on these questions, and to actually
open the debate in society.
Education is typically one
of the most important channels
for dealing with these issues,
from school onwards.
I think that afterwards, the situations
are very different from one school to another,
that now, there are things
that are changing.
However, it is certainly a combination, that the archives...
well, they weren't hidden, it was possible to access them,
but it's true, for the reasons
we've already described,
that it was very complicated.
It wasn't exactly a message of openness
to say: “let's talk about this past,
we are really
interested, politically,
in coming to terms
with the past”, etc.
So yes, clearly,
it's part of the process,
not of silence,
but I would say
of silence that is a bit variable,
or more or less hidden,
but again, that has been dealt
with by historians for decades already.
Another small question.
You mentioned the archives
in Rwanda, Burundi and the DRC,
archives from the colonial period.
What is there in these archives?
Is there... What are we...
To what extent
can they be used?
So, yes...
I think they are mobilizable...
There are big differences, I think,
between the different collections.
So, personally, I haven't worked
on these archives, from that time,
in these three countries, in the field,
so I can't say exactly
what their contents are either,
because I don't have
personal experience of that.
There is a series of preserved archives
that were produced during the colonial period.
Local archives
produced by local authorities.
I know that there are still archives,
particularly on the question of the police force
if we take the Congo,
well, the DRC.
So that was the colonial army,
so a series of files that are still kept on site.
My two colleagues on the current project on which I am working
have just returned from a mission there,
and were able to see
these collections.
In Burundi, we also have a series of documents
that are in the national archives.
Obviously, these three countries
have national archives
that are facing many material
and financial difficulties,
and have also suffered
from crises, conflicts and wars
in recent decades.
So there are documents, which are not
extremely numerous, I think,
but there are indeed documents
in these three centers,
produced at different levels.
Then there are all the archives
of the religious congregations.
There too, for example for Rwanda,
there we can think of Kabgayi,
the bishop's residence where
there are documents dating from that time.
So we really have both national archives
and decentralized archives in these countries.
This breaks the image of “there are no documents”,
because we often say that.
Finally, to make the history,
to take in the facts, in a general way, of Africa.
Yes, but “we have no documents”,
that is totally false, obviously.
There are a lot of documents that exist, have existed
and that unfortunately, sometimes have disappeared.
However, we can really
reject the idea that there are no documents.
If we take the example
of Rwanda, obviously in '94,
there was a great loss of a very large
number of documents that date
perhaps more from the post-colonial period,
but, I think, also from the colonial period,
which suffered from destruction,
displacement, theft, looting, etc.
I'm going to ask you
a very last question
that is a little...
it's not the easiest
or most convenient.
In fact, I have the impression
that we are on these...
well, that we are
in these debates on...
on questions of memory and that we realize
to what extent, this is a feeling I had,
an impression I had when I attended
the trial of the Mestizo women.
It is to see to what extent these...
historians and archives
in this context,
have a central role.
It is extremely central, both to allow access
and to be able to say what's inside.
Therefore, there is a kind
of role of guardian...
yes, of guardian to a certain...
well, to allow access to a certain memory,
to certain realities that many people ignore.
There is an extremely...
well, whether we like it or not,
very political role.
That's the first element.
A second element that we talked about
is to see to what extent,
in fact, all of this...
as you were saying,
the content of the archives is a given point
of view, at a given time, in a given context,
and here, more in a colonial context with all
the symmetry of power that we are aware of.
I have the impression that
from the point of view of the people who...
who are, well who...
who are mobilizing...
on these... well, in any case
on these questions, we are...
we have to rely on...
well, it's a bit... I'm doing the same...
I'm thinking, but I'm making the same analogy
with the law. I have the impression that we need
the law, but at the same time, it's not what...
it's not the tool
that simplifies our lives.
So, we need jurists, they have a political role,
but there is a whole legislative apparatus
that in fact allows us to justify
and give a certain point of view
of the violence of colonization.
So how do you, as a historian,
place yourself in this?
Because there's something about... Okay...
there is a political role,
but at the same time, people are,
well many historians are saying:
“Well, in fact, we have...”
Well, that's also true of...
we're going to have a neutral position
to work on documents on which
we try to bring out a neutral message.
However, no, there is nothing
neutral in this story.
So, my question is a bit scattered,
but I think you see what you...
well, you see what I mean,
this sort of positioning
in a debate that is
fortunately political,
but where this...
this presence of history is
at the same time a guarantee, well, a necessity,
but at the same time a danger,
I think, both for you,
but also for the people
who rely on to it.
Yes, the question is, do they need me or not?
[LAUGHTER]
Not so much...
No, not at all. I'm just kidding. No, no.
From me, definitely not,
as an individual, that is for sure.
But... I think
it's a very important question because...
It's true that
I don't call it “political”...
You can call it “engaged”.
It's a fundamental question,
because it's been a while
since historians are no longer, well,
most of them are no longer in the positivist idea
of objectivity,
complete neutrality, etc.
History, like all the other disciplines
in the humanities and social sciences,
has integrated the fact that our point of view,
our analysis, is constructed in a given context.
We live in our time,
so we are not... Well, I say “we”,
I don't want to speak for everyone else.
I am not disconnected from realities.
Besides, these realities, they interest me,
they fuel me on a daily basis.
In a way, what we call the social demand
for history or for memory
are two different things,
but we see them a lot in societies today.
I think that, in fact, it is fundamental.
On the one hand, I would say
that I need, as a researcher —
I speak for myself — as a researcher, I need
to feel free to make
choices and ask questions.
So to not feel like I'm being forced
into a research agenda.
While being completely open to help, guide,
open up avenues, think about questions.
However, I think that this is something
very important, this freedom to search.
It is obviously fundamental.
On the other hand, to counterbalance that,
and to try to answer all the elements brought,
this research that I am going to carry out,
I take my example, but I mean in an abstract way,
it also needs this social demand.
If there is no interest,
if no one cares,
if there is no public funding, if...
or private foundations even, there you go,
if there is no incentive behind this research,
and if this research cannot
also produce something for society,
then it is useless.
What we are asked
to do is to publish
in scientific journals, etc.,
but also to contribute
to debates, to contribute to knowledge
and in all... I would say, in humbleness.
That is to say, being conscious of the limits
of our own work, because this limit
can be many things,
it can be the languages we master,
it can be the possibilities
we have had to consult documents,
it can be the interpretation
we make of certain things,
but which nevertheless
brings something.
So history is not
something static.
I think it's important to point that out.
It is even more true in subjects like these,
which are treated by different authorities:
justice, civil society, historians,
education. Not only teaching
in schools, but also in universities.
This is also a real question.
But so...
It is extremely important that all this
remains connected, but without losing this freedom.
Without losing this freedom
because I think that...
then we'll come to the question of expertise.
A historian, a jurist or a sociologist,
who is called upon in a trial
to shed light on the past
or on a social issue.
This does exist, of course.
There are many examples in history, many trials.
It is especially the trials for crimes against humanity,
for war crimes, for crimes of genocide,
in which we observe all this.
There, it is again a different role.
However, if we talk about research,
for me, research
must be part of this society,
but I would not say by seeking
this neutrality, but on the other hand,
by seeking how to say that...
a subjectivity that is necessarily there,
because the questions that we ask,
they are necessarily dictated by many things.
The discussion we're having today
will undoubtedly, at one point or another,
lead to a question that I will ask myself
in a research project.
It's great because
it's obviously a dialogue.
However, this is
obviously subjective.
Simply the way in which
one answers this question,
it must be based on...
I think it should
be based on all those elements we talked about
at the beginning of the interview.
That is to say,
the criticism of sources,
the fact of... not to bringing
preconceived ideas about the sources,
not to look for that answer,
whatever it may be, or to reinforce that thesis,
but to be open to elements
that may contradict that thesis.
Basically, I would say, to respect the voices
that we find in the archives, or the people we interview,
when we do oral history.
I mean, it's a bit of ethics.
I don't know, research ethics.
I think that's what's fundamental.
There, all the tools of the researcher
make it possible to answer these questions,
which may be subjective,
but which are framed, through these tools.
So I believe that it is there where the borders
between politics, history and memory are drawn,
without these borders preventing
the exchange of ideas
beyond these.
That's very important.
Then each one defines for himself
what role he wants to play,
in what role he wants
to play, of course.
I don't know if this answers to...
because... but don't hesitate...
Yes, fine.
...if it doesn't.
Look, this is great.
Anyway, I think that all the elements
that we discussed here, we can put them...
well, put them even more
in debate with the...
when you come to make your presentation
with the members of CaCoBuRwa.
Thank you very much and...
and so we'll see you
in a few weeks.
Thank you very much.